from the New York Post McCarthy demands
Biden give us his bank statements as
impeachment Pro blooms okay so we can
get a little worked up I guess about oh
look he's going after Biden's bank
statements but I just want to point out
why is he only asking now for well it's
it's because he's dropping grains of
sand every week where it's like oh if if
Joe Biden if we find out that he's a
little bit more corrupt than we already
know He is we might actually ask each
other whether or not we should ask the
government for the authority to ask for
bank statements to maybe question an
impeachment the old phrase is boob bait
for the Bubbas
that's what that is yeah what is that
McCarthy's not going to kind of you know
you kind of as he as as uh as Tim was
pointing out if just a little bit to
keep your your base excited and
motivated but not do enough and and I
have to I I largely agree with Democrat
critiques of Republican concerns about
corruption that it's a lot a lot of it
is political they kind of want to use it
to get some votes now and again keep the
other side on on their heels but when it
comes to like accountability they're
fearful of it and they don't want to do
it and so and so here this is uh the
danger here is for McCarthy and
Republicans is that they just keep
stringing this along
everyone's going to see this as
political what you know stop what you
know fish or cut bait guys we don't need
another hearing
we don't need another report we don't
need another email release Judicial
Watch can write reports I can I we
release emails what does Congress do
they can defund they can make criminal
referrals they can impeach
McCarthy had any any guts what'd he do
right now is he say all these committees
investigating you know the house
oversight committee the weaponization
committee Judiciary Committee the
homeland security committee you're all
part of the impeachment inquiry okay and
now we're all gearing towards
impeachment we're going to figure out
who to impeach uh from you know lower
level officials you know like like Meyer
orcus all the way up to the president of
the United States just do it that sounds
glorious you think that they're not
going to do any of that I know but it
still sounds glorious well they might
they might as someone you know I tell
you my understanding is house members
are getting a lot of pushback on their
failure to do what folks like Tom fitten
are suggesting and so it's not like
we're speaking into the wind here there
are many many Republicans and
conservatives in the base of the
Republican party and more than a few
honest Democrats want something done
about Biden corruption and they're tired
of this
what we're seeing here give us the you
know engaging in performance fighting uh
isn't going to satisfy you know we've
been through this before time and time
again is it donor driven is that why
they don't want to go to the mat on this
that they they would lose there must be
corporate interests that make them not
want to go this route because I don't
understand it otherwise because like
their base would be jumping for joy they
would be re-elected in a landslide so
probably they want to wait for it they
want to wait till an election well you
know I don't want to say that there's no
political downside to doing this and you
know I I would admit there might be yeah
but I mean do they have a choice I mean
what like I mean Kenya Kenya not not
impeach Biden at this point I don't see
how you not do it maybe they're looking
for like golden evidence before they
push forward because if they want US
bank statements they're looking for
connections to barisma and Hunter and
then maybe that'll be they didn't ask
for the bank statements
you know they spent the last six months
and I think there was some smart
activity there in that regard well it's
like let's get into let's get to a fight
with Hunter and Joe first bank
statements we can get all these other
bank statements pretty easily and that's
what they did and so now it's now August
they're all on vacation and they're
talking about well maybe we'll start
asking for the Biden uh James you know
Hunter Biden or I don't know I'm
assuming Joe Biden's bank statements
I mean I don't know what Joe Biden's
bank statements are going to show my
guess is you know who's paying his
contractor fees up in Delaware I mean no
he didn't he doesn't pay any bills no
that's company was paying all the bills
they got to do more than bank statements
Hunter is The Bag Man I want everyone to
understand that the money was being
funneled through these corrupt business
cutouts
into Hunter's bank accounts but then
Hunter was responsible for taking care
of all of the expenditures for the
entire Biden family that's the whole way
they circumvented this folks it's like
it's pretty obvious at this point if
you've paid any intention at all that's
what they did Biden doesn't ever touch
the money that's how he gets away with
it there's a crisis for the political
system here in Washington DC because
they've known Biden's been corrupt since
he's a senator he's been in Washington
50 years this is not a surprise to folks
who serve with them and people around
him and the problem the political system
has is now half the country believe him
to be corrupt too so now they don't know
what to do about it hence McCarthy's
confusion about whether their support or
not support an impeachment inquiry and
like if they ripped it open and he was
super corrupt and then got impeached and
had to step down we'd have Kamala Harris
as president and like is that are we
even better off is that yeah that's
going through people's heads yeah if
it's just if that's you know if Justice
results if that's what Justice results
in you know that's the reality of it and
I mean just think about an impeachment
inquiry I mean they're not you know
they're still presuming to to say that
well we don't know if we're going to
impeach him or not I mean come on
because because Justice it's like how
when do you put the brakes on Justice
you know you could rip the rip it open
on Kamal Harris's bank records next you
can go into Willie Brown Next you could
go into like her old text message like
how deep do you want to go to take out
every new leader that steps in you guys
are some dumb corruption Scandal you
actually but it's not done though I want
to be very clear this is not dumb if if
you are actually like there's a really
good chance that Russia doesn't invade
if it's not for Biden's relationship
with barisma and the leadership not to
mention the state department coup not to
mention Victoria Newland like there's a
whole bunch of back history here that
yes there's minor seemingly millions of
dollars worth of corruption in terms of
what they profited but what does it mean
in terms of the outcome for geopolitical
Dynamics like we could end up in World
War III because we were led by a corrupt
president during this period because
you're telling Russia and China if you
compromise our president we're going to
remove him from office or move to remove
him I mean barisma was a Russia leading
con government entity I mean what I
loved about that 1023 that FBI form that
described uh the head of barisma's bribe
scheme for the bidens so the FBI Source
goes and says you know we had the
meeting and it was all in Russian so
baristma was you know so between Russia
uh giving them money through the
oligarch's wife that was further
confirmed last week who is that what's
the wife's name um Maria what's her face
the mayor of moscow's uh ex-wife yeah
yeah so it was like three and you know
Devin Archer essentially confirmed they
sent millions of dollars to their
companies and all of which they shared
uh and then barisma you have FBI
allowance he gave 10 million they gave
10 million dollars to the bidens
and so if you're Putin to your point
Clinton you're thinking well you know
I'm not going to invade Ukraine because
Biden's on the tank and I know he is
because we compromised them but
certainly that would be a factor don't
you think
that the country's not stable well DC
you know Biden can be caught he's
compromised he can be talked to you know
he knows we know about them
well we had documents where during the
Obama Administration uh the Ukrainian
Ambassador was getting an email from her
person just before bide went to Ukraine
in January of 2021 just before Trump
came in
and the Russians started trolling him
literally trolling him in the newspapers
well keep in mind too because the
barisma and and the and the Obama's
Ambassador said you know was told well
this is this is the barisma is the gift
that keeps on giving so they knew that
the Biden issue was compromising our
national security visa and keep in mind
too Hunter Biden was the lead Envoy for
the U.S to Ukraine under Barack Obama's
administration in 2014 when that coup
happens that's largely a state
department Victoria Newland LED uh
Fiasco so like this this is a
long-running dynamic and people get
caught up on like just this one 12 month
or 18-month period of History it's very
important that you understand the entire
encompassing 20-year period or better
yet go all the way back to 91 in the
USSR and when the the wall fell and then
the go back to Afghanistan CIA is
funding the a lot of jihadim to to ruin
the Russians quick shout out to my guy
Scott Horton he's gonna new book called
provoke that's coming out in like I
don't know sometimes it's amazing it's
an amazing book that's the whole reason
I know about all this history he's been
incredible Mike Flynn was indicted by
the justice department General Flynn for
not registering as a foreign agent
because he worked for uh Turkish
non-profit not the Turkish government of
Turkish nonprofit closely is linked to
the government
now there's even more significant and
Powerful evidence that Joe Biden isn't
unregistered foreign agent vis-a-vis the
Chinese and the Russians yep
you know if it's good if you know Trump
should have done more it's like when you
look at it it seems so overwhelming and
like what in the hell these pieces but
when you look at it in the future when
you look back on it it will make perfect
sense well here's the problem too the
reason and I asked him earlier why are
they not pursuing the defunding of all
this why are they not pursuing this
investigation as they should my opinion
is that both sides of the aisle are
comparably dirty when it comes to
Ukraine in particular they they were I
mean you have Chris Christie yeah well
Chris Christie but he said his audience
supports his efforts his views on
Ukraine and thinks we're not doing
enough yeah it's nonsense I don't know
anybody on the GOP side that actually
feels that way but you have Lindsey
Graham you have uh you have John McCain
that are over in Ukraine in 2018 going
next year is the year of offense I mean
this is a long-running thing man and
it's both sides of the aisle that were
like they were cha-chingen you got Mitt
Romney got Nancy Pelosi they're all
making money off this crap so if
question for you guys if the United
States pivots and is like you know we're
going to settle this war peacetime we're
giving we're seated we're going to sell
Eastern dombas to the Russians for 350
trillion dollars or whatever the hell
it's going to go to the bank it's going
to pay for reconstruction the Russians
will pay for it the Russians say yes if
that happens yes will they stop there
will they go for for turkey will they
try and seize Istanbul so that they have
a trade route into the Mediterranean or
are we good to go did we just appease
Hitler for the second time or is this
actually peace I think it's over at that
point I honestly do
that's my honest opinion
yeah I think if if if the war settles
with the Russians keeping a little bit
of Ukraine and Crimea that will probably
you know there'll be a tense
you know a tense piece for a decade and
frankly it depends on the western
leadership I mean the Russians are you
know they will push where they think
they can push and if they don't think
they can get anywhere
they won't right thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time